[Musique]
est ce que vous savez combien de temps
mettait un cyclone a passé de la
catégorie 1 à la catégorie 5 en 1950
environ deux semaines
aujourd'hui les cyclones tropicaux
peuvent passer à la puissance maximale
en 24 heures comment cela est-il
possible
la température de l'eau joue un rôle
essentiel au sein du cyclone d'orient
les vents atteignaient la vitesse de 360
km heure c'était la même chose pour irma
et pour maria sur notre terre le record
de vitesse des ventes à ce jour c'était
en 1999 dans l'oklahoma au coeur d'une
tornade avec 512 km heure à de telles
vitesses
même le bitume des routes de s'arracher
pour tant du point de vue des
astrophysiciens ces vitesses sont tout à
fait banal dans le système solaire et
même dans l'univers sur mars comme sur
vénus les vents peuvent atteindre
régulièrement la vitesse de 540
kilomètres heures au pôle ou au fond
d'un canyon sur jupiter la planète
jupiter
les vents peuvent atteindre au coeur des
cyclones la vitesse de 600 kilomètres à
l'heure vous avez été fier de cyclone
comme on en a dans l'atlantique mais
beaucoup plus nombreux avec une vitesse
moyenne de 600 kilomètres heure vous
avez une grande tache rouge sur jupiter
énorme c'est un cyclone qui pourrait
contenir la terre toute entière sur
saturne la planète aux anneaux
les vents atteignent
800 km par an et le record à battre sur
notre système solaire c'est la planète
suivante c'est neptune avec 2100
kilomètres heure des vitesses comme ça
c'est difficile à se représenter
c'est deux fois la vitesse du son c'est
la vitesse d'un concorde lancé à pleine
vitesse
pourtant ça nous donne une idée de ce
qui pourrait bien nous arriver sur notre
planète
avec l'accélération des effets du
réchauffement climatique notre terre et
comme une île perdue au milieu de
l'océan comme une île de la caraïbe
si notre terre cas de crise majeure
devenue inhabitable
pourrions nous aller coloniser les
planètes voisines je vais prendre pour
commencer l'exemple de la planète mars
mars qui est une planète en ce moment
qui attire les explorateurs depuis
plusieurs siècles d'ailleurs avec en
tête le milliardaire et le losc
vous savez ce milliardaire un peu fou et
saisissez rêve d'aller sur mars mais qui
emmène quand même un rêve extraordinaire
qu'en est il dans la réalité
astrophysique mars et l habitables sur
le plan purement astrophysique mars et
deux fois plus petit que notre terre la
gravité y est trois fois moins grande
je pèse 65 kg ici je reposerai environ
25 sur la terre sur pardon sur mars mars
avait autrefois un volcanisme actif qui
permettait la présence d'une atmosphère
épaisse et d'océans d'eau liquide
pendant les 6 100 premiers millions
d'années de la vie de mars
il y avait des océans un kilomètre
d'épaisseur à peu près et probablement
d'avis mais mars s'est refroidi le
volcanisme s'est arrêté une partie de
l'atmosphère est reparti dans l'espace
érodé par les vents du soleil
l'autre partie est rentré dans le sol
emmenant avec elle une partie de l'eau
qui a gelé dans les profondeurs de la
planète rendre mars habitable
aujourd'hui supposerait de faire ce que
l'on appelle de la terraformation
littéralement
se former marc santerre pour ce faire
des projets ont été évoqués comme par
exemple projet un peu science-fiction
jeudi et pourtant on en parle
sérieusement le premier serait de
balancer des bombes atomiques au pôle
nord et au pôle sud pour faire fondre la
glace et relancer le dynamisme
volcaniques
faire fondre et glace remettre des
océans on voit bien que si jamais il ya
de la vie c'est pas terrible du point de
vue de la radioactivité
c'est pas génial pourtant c'est un
projet qui est évoqué le deuxième projet
pas trop vite les images
le deuxième projet consisterait à aller
attraper un astéroïde qui passe quelque
part entre mars et jupiter et le
balancer sur la planète
l'impact du choc créerait un lac de
fonte autour duquel on s'installerait
avec des petites plantes des petites
fleurs et on pourrait planter des arbres
pour progressivement modifier
l'atmosphère
pas sûr que ça marche surtout ça
pourrait créer des dégâts écologiques
majeurs le troisième projet alors là ça
serait là les installer des aimants
géant au pôle nord et au pôle sud sur
des structures gonflables pour recréer
un champ magnétique et ainsi protéger la
planète des vents solaires et recréer
une atmosphère pour permettre de faire
revenir la vie on voit bien que tout ça
est pas très réaliste
si vous voulez mon opinion la seule
chose qu'on peut réellement imaginer
d'ici la fin de ce siècle et bien des
petites colonies scientifique avec des
villages par exemple en forme de dôme où
on irait faire que des missions mais ça
paraît pas du tout réaliste de faire ce
travail-là venus maintenant la planète
vénus que vous avez ici venus c'est le
problème inverse
là il ya eu trop d effet de serre c'est
à dire un volcanisme actif tellement
actif qu'il a lâché des tonnes de
milliards de tonnes de co2 qui ont
interagi avec des océans qui existe est
peut-être à l'époque il y a
150 millions d'années il y avait qu on
pense maintenant des océans d'eau
liquide aussi et la surface de vénus
comme quoi y avait de l'eau partout dans
le système solaire et le co2 a fait
monter la température évaporer l'eau qui
a créé un effet de serre la machine
s'est emballée et aujourd'hui sur vénus
la température est de 4 190 degrés deux
fois la température nécessaire pour
faire cuire un poulet dans le four donc
je vous souhaite de bonnes vacances
je passe rapidement sur les planètes
plus lointaine de jupiter saturne en
avoir assez moins 180 degrés on sait
même pas si un sol sur lequel on peut
marcher
donc on va aller tout de suite plus loin
tout le monde en parle vous avez entendu
parler sûrement des exoplanètes les
exoplanètes qui doivent arriver
normalement la plus proche
elle est à 4 années lumières alors
quatre années lumière ça veut dire 60
bilan de voyage avec les réseaux actuels
dans le meilleur des cas d'ici la fin du
siècle 2100 on va dire 400 ans quatre
siècles de voyage alors imaginez dans
cette salle nous sommes tous là nous
décidons de partir pour un voyage de
quatre siècles visiter une planète dont
on ne sait même pas si elle est
réellement habitable
alors vous passer au guichet vous signez
une décharge de responsabilité
je m'engage à partir à faire les enfants
bien sûr ça m'est nécessaire à vieillir
et à mourir dans ce vaisseau est allégué
la responsabilité mes enfants alors
c'est très bien on va le faire peut-être
trouver le temps long
vous connaissez la phrase de woody allen
il y disait l'éternité c'est long
surtout vers la fin d'une génération
douze générations alors les enfants qui
vont monter dans ce petit vaisseau qui
vont naître dans ce vaisseau es qu'ils
auront demandé à naître et quand on va
dire et ben écoute mon fils tu va naître
là tu va grandir tu vas faire des
enfants tu va vieillir tu vas mourir tu
veux est ce qu'il va être d'accord
imaginez la consanguinité l'absence de
soleil la nourriture qui sera
probablement quelque peu monotone
est ce que c'est pour cette raison que
l'extraterrestre it y avait cette tête
quand il est arrivé sur le terrain
non soyons réalistes franchement notre
terre et notre maison pour encore de
nombreuses années
nous vivons actuellement un moment
unique dans l'histoire de l'humanité
nous attendons des bouleversements
majeurs à l'échelle de la planète
l'objectif à atteindre à tout prix
pourrait se résumer en peu de mots nous
devons tout faire pour garder notre
planète habitable et désirable cette
formule dramatique implique ce que nous
connaissons tous maintenant déjà notre
planète pourrait devenir inhabitable
avec tout ce que cela comporte de
conséquences pour nous mêmes nos enfants
et nos petits enfants
les éléments requis pour atteindre cet
objectif sont connus ils impliquent des
bouleversements majeurs dans nos
comportements nous ne retrouveront plus
jamais l'état de notre planète telle
qu'elle était à l'époque pré
industrielle
il y à 60 ans 70 ans seulement depuis
plusieurs décennies
dès la fin de la première guerre
mondiale des inquiétudes se sont fait
entendre qu'ils n'ont pas été prises au
sérieux
aujourd'hui elles remplissent le contenu
des médias grâce aux études de monsieur
diamond sur les civilisations disparues
nous connaissons assez bien maintenant
les séquence d'événements qui conduisent
à l'effondrement de ces groupes humains
il s'agit la plupart du temps de
surexploitation des ressources
naturelles forêts pêcheries agriculture
menant tête une désertification des
territoires
en parallèle avec une augmentation
démesurée des populations et de leurs
exigences des symptômes que nous n'avons
pas suffisamment pris en compte ces
dernières années dans notre globalité
planétaire déjà de nombreuses
initiatives fleurissent un peu partout
dans le monde pour remédier à la
situation
nous sommes maintenant en présence de
deux forces qui sont dans une lutte sans
merci
deux forces qui s'opposent et prennent
de la puissance continuellement l'une à
la force de destruction dont on vient de
parler
le cyclone destruction érosion de la
biodiversité et l'autre qui est une
force de résilience qui reprend des
forces chaque jour qui représentait par
greta tune direct par exemple qui prend
la parole ici devant 500 milles
montréalais s'étaient ya à peine un mois
qui va l'emporter quel sera l'état
d'autres planètes
à la fin de ce siècle nul ne peut
prédire à l'avenir il pourrait être
meilleur il pourrait être bien pire
il dépend de décisions qui seront prises
maintenant sur le plan de la guadeloupe
la situation est particulièrement
critique le giec nous modélise une
élévation du niveau des mers d'ici la
fin du siècle d'environ 1 m 10 la
réalité est probablement bien pire
on parle de la fonte du groenland la
fonte de l'antarctique ouest des choses
qui n'ont pas été prises en compte
personnellement je tablerais sur 7 m
vous avez ici une simulation de l'état
de la guadeloupe avec une élévation
vidéo de la mère de 7 m vous voyez
pointe à pitre a disparu le littoral est
complètement transformé la guadeloupe
est coupée en deux le papillon a perdu
une aile ou deux et grande terre est
pratiquement coupée pour s'adapter à
cette situation il faut sans tarder
modifier nos comportements redessiné le
littoral les chercheurs proposent de
mettre en place des stratégies de repli
progressif plusieurs mesures pourraient
être pensée comme par exemple construire
les bâtiments administratifs des
hôpitaux les écoles plus à la r&d terre
au lieu de continuer à gaspiller de
l'argent dans des infrastructures
coûteuses comme par exemple les hôtels
de luxe où les digues comme c'est le cas
actuellement à venise ou aux maldives
on fait aussi des digues à new york mais
à new york c'est plutôt le temps de d
placer les intérêts stratégiques et
vitaux vers l'intérieur des terres il va
falloir aussi repenser la forme de nos
maisons les maisons devront être prévues
pour s'adapter à des vents de 500
kilomètres heure vous avez sur cette
image un modèle de maison qui a été
construit en 2000 à peu près à pensacola
en californie on voit tout de suite que
cette maison est beaucoup plus
aérodynamique quelle que soit la forme
du cyclone
quelle que soit la vitesse et le sens
dans lequel ils arrivent elles résistent
à des ventes 500 km heure elles
résistent aussi aux débris à c'est très
bien cette maison à résister aux
cyclones dennis en 2005 mais par contre
ils ont fait une erreur il le construit
trop près du niveau de la mer donc il va
falloir penser à ça en plus il ya en
l'an 2000 on ne supposait pas cela il
faudra aussi parler du modèle économique
de la guadeloupe qu'il faudra changer
pour aller vers l'autonomie
j'aimerais par exemple citer le tourisme
le tourisme de masse représenté ici un
paquebot de croisière comme il en
arrivera bientôt quatre par semaine à
pointe à pitre avec entre 4000 5000
peut-être 9000 personnes à bord c'est
gbagbo vous le savez maintenant consomme
énormément de fioul lourd dégage
beaucoup de gaz carbonique des figures
les rivages atteignent la flore la faune
et finalement profite assez peu à
l'économie locale puisque tout le monde
dort et mange sur le bateau est ce que
c'est ce tourisme que nous voulons alors
que un peu partout dans le monde
mais aujourd'hui un tourisme vert
écologique respectueux de
l'environnement avec par exemple des
voiliers haut des bateaux à propulsion
électrique
c'est fondamental sur le plan de
l'énergie
ici à la guadeloupe vous avez une chance
inouïe j'ai toujours été admiratif vous
avez tous vous allez du soleil vous avez
devant vous avez les alizés vous avez
des vagues
vous avez de l'eau douce en permanence
vous avez la géothermie les éoliennes le
vent accélère en permanence on parle de
500 kilomètres heure alors on vient
d'installer au moins de janvier à sainte
rose ici huit éoliennes anticyclonique
extraordinaire en une petite
télécommande qui permet de rabattre les
éoliennes en cas de cyclone
encore faut-il être prévenus à temps
parce que 24 heures c'est très court
voilà ici un modèle d'éolienne tubulaire
qui a été conçu au japon qui permet de
récupérer l'énergie des cyclones elle
tourne dans un sens et puis dans l'autre
quand on a traversé l'oeil aussi simple
que ça c'est un effet qu on a étudié en
soufflerie
il y as suffisamment d'énergie dans un
ouragan pour alimenter en électricité
l'ensemble du japon pendant 50 ans cette
idée elle est géniale mais il faut
savoir le récupérer et puis va falloir
stocker l'hydrogène par exemple pour
être une façon en fabriquant de
l'hydrogène avec le photovoltaïque
on pourrait récupérer cette énergie et
puis une autre chose très importante
avec laquelle j'aimerais terminer c'est
la géothermie
vous avez cette chance incroyable
d'avoir ici la plaque atlantique qui se
glisse sous la plaque caraïbe qui fait
de l'eau chaude qui remonte en
permanence jusqu'à de l'eau bouillante
qui remonte à bouillante
la seule centrale géothermique
actuellement l'activité avec 15
mégawatts bientôt 50 avec une troisième
plate forme de forage qui est en cours
de réalisation
l'idée serait de fédérer toutes ces
hilde avec les potentialités
géothermique pour atteindre l'autonomie
énergétique totale d'ici 2030 à 2050
pourtant aujourd'hui à par trinidad et
tobago tout s'est il importe du diesel
pour fabriquer de l'électricité
voilà ces quelques idées avec lesquelles
je voulais que vous repartiez j'aimerais
terminer avec une phrase d'un résistant
de la seconde guerre mondiale qui
s'appelle jean monnet qui disait au pire
de l'invasion nazie
l'important ce n'est pas d'être
pessimiste ni d'être optimiste
l'important c'est d'être déterminée
mesdames et messieurs et benoît reeves
[Musique]